Jake:哎你是
Jake: Hey, are you...
Jake:呃呃你得插上呀
Jake: Uh, you need to plug it in.
Jake:你们得开机呀
Jake: You need to turn it on.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What's this?
Tasha:薄荷叶
Jake:薄荷叶
Jake:薄荷叶在这
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:
我靠
Shure: 不怪你这真不怪你
Shure: It's not your fault, really.
Jake:这是蜜蜂用的吗
Jake: Is this for bees?
Jake:不能受潮还是
Jake: Shouldn't it be kept dry, or...
Jake:点外卖
Jake: Order takeout.
Jake:咱还有食材做吗
Jake: Do we still have ingredients to cook?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:要表演了
Jake: It's time to perform.
Shure: 雨轩说他想唱歌
Shure: Yuxuan says he wants to sing.
Shure: 我没有叫紫萱的
Shure: I didn't call for Zixuan.
Nicous: 我知道谁了
Nicous: I know who it is.
Nicous: 大佐
Nicous: Dazuo.
Shure: 朱子炫是吗
Shure: Zhu Zixuan, right?
Shure: 哈哈乐死了
Shure: Haha, that's hilarious.
Jake:有点沙雕
Jake: That's a bit silly.
Shure: 这时候就可以问AI他为什么要调琴
Shure: This is when you can ask AI why he tunes the instrument.
Shure: 因为我拿起这把琴的时候
Shure: Because when I picked up this instrument,
Shure: 发现的这个琴不准
Shure: I found it was out of tune.
Jake:然后就要进行这个调整
Jake: Then you need to adjust it.
Jake:以前没有这个APP的时候怎么调
Jake: How did you tune it before without this app?
Shure: 你要是问最古老吗
Shure: You mean the old way?
Jake:就是之前了
Jake: Yeah, before.
Shure: 对靠那个震动频率
Shure: Yeah, by relying on the vibration frequency.
Shure: 然后感受
Shure: And feeling it.
Jake: 然后那个多少钱
Jake: And how much did it cost?
Shure: 没没多少钱
Shure: Not much at all.
Shure: 怎么回事
Shure: What's going on?
Shure: 几十块钱不到 10新币
Shure: Less than 10 SGD.
Shure: 应该 10新币左右
Shure: Probably around 10 SGD.
Jake:300分好
Jake: 300 points, good.
Shure: 好了雨轩老师
Shure: Okay, Mr. Yuxuan.
Jake:叫对了
Jake: You got it right
Shure: 要表演了
Shure: Time to perform
Shure: 你点的轻
Shure: You tapped it lightly
Shure: 点的唯一吗
Shure: Tapped the only one?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 在来啊
Shure: Come on
Jake:彩排彩排
Jake: Rehearse, rehearse
Shure: 准备好了
Shure: Ready
Shure: 这次紫萱老师
Shure: This time, Miss Zixuan
Jake:完了
Jake: It's over
Jake:跪下来吧
Jake: Kneel down
Shure: 雨轩老师
Shure: Mr. Yuxuan
Shure: 可以了吗
Shure: Is it okay now?
Jake:这次来开拍吧
Jake: Let's start filming this time
Jake:我觉得差不多了
Jake: I think it's about right
Jake:先连一下
Jake: Let's connect first
Shure: 哈哈你搞搞事情了是吗
Shure: Haha, you causing trouble?
Shure: 哈哈哈我啊
Shure: Haha, me?
Jake:长务记一下这个
Jake: Long Wu, note this down
Jake:5:1017:11
Jake: 5:10, 17:11
Jake:对对叫什么呀
Jake: Yeah yeah, what's it called?
Shure: 对齐
Shure: Align
Jake:信口来词
Jake: Just random words
Jake:不好
Jake: Not good
Jake:停停停卡卡卡卡
Jake: Stop stop stop, cut cut cut cut
Jake:我的虫虫
Jake: My bug
Jake:对了鬼关了好好
Jake: Alright, ghost turned off, okay
Jake:再来一次
Jake: One more time
Jake:再来一次啊
Jake: One more time, alright
Jake:再来一次
Jake: One more time
Lucia:怎么回事
Lucia: What's going on?
Jake:刚刚我
Jake: Just now, I
Jake:走一半关了
Jake: Halfway through, it turned off
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:你俩要不做个狗
Jake: Why don't you two act like dogs?
Jake:啊我们一起来做狗吧
Jake: Ah, let's all act like dogs together.
Alice:我们一起来做狗
Alice: Let's all act like dogs together.
Jake:对
Jake:露亚 对露亚来指导一下
Jake: Lucia, yeah, let Lucia guide it a bit.
Lucia:可以啊我我这个马上快完工了
Lucia: Sure, I'm almost done with this.
Jake:好 好嘞
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia:III believe so
Lucia: III believe so.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:我们来quarter一下
Jake: Let's quarter it.
Lucia:不是但是他
Lucia: No, but he...
Lucia:嗯我觉得还是有什么地方好像
Lucia: Um, I think there's still something...
Jake:好像不太准了
Jake: It seems a bit off.
Lucia:对就这个
Lucia: Yeah, this part.
Lucia:这玩意他应该能但是其实也没事
Lucia: This thing should work, but actually, it's fine.
Lucia:实在不行就不安里面
Lucia: If it doesn't work, we won't install it.
Lucia:结果把这冲墙
Lucia: Just push it against the wall.
Jake:哎这个为什么
Jake: Hey, why not?
Jake:不行不行我试试看
Jake: No, no, let me try.
Lucia:你有强迫症啊哈
Lucia: Are you OCD or something?
Jake:呃可以有一点
Jake: Uh, maybe a little.
Lucia:OK
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:这个首先这个是对上的对吧
Jake: First, this part matches, right?
Lucia:对这是对上的
Lucia: Yeah, it matches.
Lucia:因为呢一会我们把它方便装进去
Lucia: Because later we need to install it conveniently.
Lucia:也不用拼那么死
Lucia: No need to fit it tightly.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What's this?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 那我应该知道
Shure: Then I should know.
Lucia:而且就是过几天可能还要把它拆开
Lucia: Besides, we might need to take it apart in a few days.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake:哦对对对
Jake: Oh, right, right.
Jake:这个可能是放后面
Jake: This one might go in the back.
Lucia:这玩意怎么又掉下来了
Lucia: Why did this fall again?
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:就是它社
Lucia: It's just that...
Jake:哪个是放后面来着
Jake: Which one goes in the back again?
Lucia:呃这个上面有说明书
Lucia: Uh, there's a manual for that.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:就是这个这框这样拼的
Lucia: This frame goes like this.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia:然后所以我觉得吧
Lucia: So, I think...
Lucia:就是这个有有底下有这一条的
Lucia: There's a strip on the bottom.
Jake:对应该是挂准这样的
Jake: Yeah, it should hang like this.
Lucia:就是他好像是在这就是有一条的
Lucia: It seems like there's a strip here.
Lucia:跟这个连着
Lucia: Connect it with this.
Lucia:你觉得呢
Lucia: What do you think?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:是这意思不
Lucia: Is that what it means?
Jake:我试试
Jake: I'll give it a try.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Lucia:没事没事我会把它修好了
Lucia: It's okay, I'll fix it.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia:对吧
Lucia: Right?
Lucia:所以理论上应该是就是不是你
Lucia: So theoretically, it's not you...
Lucia:你看一眼
Lucia: Take a look.
Jake:哈哈我知道我知道我知道
Jake: Haha, I know, I know, I know.
Jake:理论上是这么回事
Jake: Theoretically, that's it.
Lucia:对理论上他应该是这是跟这走的OK
Lucia: Yeah, theoretically, this should follow this, OK?
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:哦 哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Jake:ok
Jake: OK.
Lucia:然后
Lucia: Then...
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia:但是反正总之就是我安进去之后吧
Lucia: But anyway, after I install it...
Jake:啊
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:他他他总是有哪不太对劲
Lucia: There's always something not quite right.
Jake:ok
Jake: OK.
Lucia:就好像是长或者宽就对
Lucia: It's like, the length or width isn't right.
Lucia:然后这样把它推进去
Lucia: Then push it in like this.
Jake:哎  哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Lucia:但是就是我刚才推它推不到里边
Lucia: But just now, I couldn't push it all the way in.
Lucia:它会就有一点在外边露着
Lucia: It sticks out a little bit.
Lucia:就它没有办法完全融这个抽屉
Lucia: It can't fully fit into the drawer.
Lucia:融入不了柜子
Lucia: It doesn't fit into the cabinet.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:等会我先把底下这个修好啊
Lucia: Wait, let me fix this part first.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:好稍微按一下就好了
Lucia: Just press it a bit and it should be fine.
Lucia:哈哈这被咱俩折腾完
Lucia: Haha, after all our tinkering...
Lucia:这玩意还能用不
Lucia: Will this thing still work?
Shure: 哈哈哈要唱他的原原调的
Shure: Hahaha, we need to sing its original tune.
Jake:要不就是空心的嘛对吧总有
Jake: Or it's just hollow inside, right? There's always...
Jake:乞丐方案
Jake: A makeshift solution.
Jake:还有板吗
Jake: Any more boards?
Jake:还有看到
Jake: And also, see this?
Lucia:有吧
Lucia: Yeah, I see it.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:但是接下来就是那三个配套的抽屉
Lucia: But next are those three matching drawers.
Lucia:其实就完事了
Lucia: Actually, that's it.
Lucia:这还挺好装的
Lucia: They're pretty easy to assemble.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia:都是一些榫牟结构
Lucia: They all use mortise and tenon joints.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia:差不多就这样但是再稍微轻点
Lucia: That's about it, but go a bit lighter.
Lucia:因为我后面装的不是很使劲
Lucia: Because I didn't use much force on the back.
Lucia:我怕太用劲把压的那啥了对
Lucia: I'm afraid if I use too much force, it might press too hard.
Lucia:你先按要不
Lucia: You press first, maybe?
Jake:我先按上面的
Jake: I'll press the top first.
Lucia:可以
Lucia: Sure.
Jake:哎就直接直接上来就系了吗
Jake: Hey, do I just tie it directly?
Lucia:就总觉得有点有哪里不对
Lucia: It feels like something's not quite right.
Jake:哎哎这个像这么回事
Jake: Hey, this looks like it.
Jake:哎不像了
Jake: Hey, now it doesn't.
Lucia:哈哈哈又不像了
Lucia: Haha, now it doesn't look like it.
Jake:像应该还是像的
Jake: It should look like it.
Jake:可能得是
Jake: Maybe it needs to...
Jake:这个稍微出来一点呀
Jake: This needs to come out a bit.
Lucia:是不是卡的呀
Lucia: Is it stuck?
Lucia:好像是这么回事吧
Lucia: Seems like that's the case.
Jake:挺好挺好挺好挺好挺好
Jake: Good, good, good, good, good.
Lucia:就这样就这样就这样嗯挺好
Lucia: Just like this, just like this, yeah, good.
Jake:大成功大成功
Jake: Big success, big success.
Jake:每天都在成功
Jake: Succeeding every day.
Lucia:每天都在成功
Lucia: Succeeding every day.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Alice:中间好像断开了
Alice: It seems like there's a disconnect in the middle.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: Not a big deal.
Lucia:这里就再把它再按一下就好了
Lucia: Just press it again here and it's fine.
Lucia:因为这个东西他都插进去
Lucia: Because this thing, it just slots in.
Lucia:他没有螺丝
Lucia: There are no screws.
Lucia:所以就是这个
Lucia: So, this...
Lucia:这个地方如果就不能太使劲
Lucia: This part shouldn't be forced too hard.
Lucia:如果太使劲的话
Lucia: If you force it too hard...
Lucia:他这个这个地方就会就会脱出来
Lucia: This part here will come off.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Mm, okay.
Alice:外面在干嘛呢
Alice: What's going on outside?
Lucia:稍等一下
Lucia: Hold on a second.
Jake:在
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:哎看看这是他就会出来
Lucia: Hey, look, it'll come off like this.
Jake:好去吧
Jake: Okay, go ahead.
Alice:他们在干嘛
Alice: What are they doing?
Jake:他们在唱歌啊
Jake: They're singing.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia:外面可以卡拉OK吗
Lucia: Can we do karaoke outside?
Jake:对他们在唱歌啊
Jake: Yeah, they're singing.
Jake:可以一会啊
Jake: You can in a bit.
Jake:对去吧
Jake: Yes, go ahead.
Jake:哎这怎么对不上了
Jake: Hey, why doesn't this match?
Jake:对上了对上了
Jake: Oh, it matches now.
Lucia:就是要因为它都是一些塑料板
Lucia: Yeah, because these are all plastic panels.
Lucia:对然后把它插个大概进去就完事了
Lucia: Right, then just insert it in a bit and it's done.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia:稍等一下啊
Lucia: Hold on a second.
Jake:这个会堵死
Jake: This will get clogged.
Lucia:这个就是理论上它要按紧
Lucia: Theoretically, it should be pressed tightly.
Jake:哦给它
Jake: Oh, give it...
Lucia:然后稍等
Lucia: Then hold on.
Jake:哦好行
Jake: Oh, okay.
Lucia:我先把这个放哪去了
Lucia: I'll put this away first.
Jake:理伦上要按紧咱就不按紧
Jake: Theoretically, it should be pressed tightly, but we won't.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: : 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia:因为这个摁紧环还有点难摁
Lucia: Because it's hard to press this ring tightly.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好的咱就不按紧
Jake: Alright, we won't press it tightly.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Lucia:前面这个地方
Lucia: This part here.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:对就就最下面上
Lucia: Yeah, just the bottom part.
Lucia:刚才有最下面拉垮
Lucia: The bottom part was loose earlier.
Lucia:好像有点
Lucia: Seems like a bit.
Lucia:哪里卡着了似的
Lucia: Like something is stuck.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay
Lucia:sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Lucia:这还要卡一下
Lucia: We need to clip this too
Lucia:因为这就是要把这个东西卡也
Lucia: Because we need to clip this thing as well
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Lucia:卡到这一层
Lucia: Clip it to this layer
Lucia:他也是那个塑料壳那个地方
Lucia: It's also at that plastic shell part
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Lucia:嗯对着这样子
Lucia: Yeah, like this
Lucia:嗯对好了前面点
Lucia: Yeah, align it a bit more to the front
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia:然后这个也是一个道理
Lucia: Then it's the same principle
Lucia:同理可证
Lucia: Same logic applies
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh wow
Lucia:他好像对我的说法不是很满意
Lucia: He doesn't seem very satisfied with my explanation
Jake:他不要被证明
Jake: He doesn't want to be proved
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no
Lucia:没事充电宝掉了没事
Lucia: It's okay, the power bank fell, no worries
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:问题不大
Jake: Not a big problem
Jake:我们今晚
Jake: Tonight
Jake:做什么呀
Jake: What are we doing
Jake:薄荷
Jake: Mint
Tasha:提拉米苏啊
Tasha: Tiramisu
Jake:好
Jake: Great
Tasha:那尽快躲
Tasha: Then hurry up
Tasha:他还要冷藏呢
Tasha: It needs to be chilled
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:现在就做
Jake: Let's do it now
Jake:好
Jake: Alright
Lucia:好了
Lucia: Done
Lucia: 这个您怎么放的来着
Lucia: How did you place this again
Tasha:好还有肉松小贝
Tasha: Oh, and there's also meat floss cake
Tasha:想吃哪一个
Tasha: Which one do you want
Shure: 这不是唯一唯一是
Shure: This isn't the only one, the only one is
Jake:哎
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: Either is fine
Lucia:两个天菜都很好吃
Lucia: Both options are delicious
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Jake:有点歪
Jake: It's a bit crooked
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why is that?
Lucia:啊还行啊就这样吧
Lucia: Ah, it's okay, just leave it like that.
Lucia:管他呢嗯
Lucia: Whatever, yeah.
Jake:嗯 挺好
Jake: Hmm, it's pretty good.
Jake:哦 应该是没有合警他歪就歪了是吧
Jake: Oh, it might be because it's not tightly fitted, so it got crooked, right?
Jake:合紧可能就好了
Jake: If it was tighter, it might be fine.
Lucia:哦你说
Lucia: Oh, you mean...
Jake:嘿嘿嘿
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia:尴尬
Lucia: Awkward.
Jake:不太抗地震
Jake: It's not very earthquake-resistant.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:是啊这个地方稍微有点歪
Lucia: Yeah, this part is a bit crooked.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Lucia:没事这这个这个这面就是墙
Lucia: It's okay, this side is just a wall.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:你可以这样
Lucia: You can do it like this.
Lucia:就这样解决了
Lucia: Just solve it like this.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Lucia:不行把它再压压
Lucia: No, press it down more.
Lucia:能压紧一点
Lucia: Can you press it tighter?
Jake:压紧一点
Jake: Press it tighter.
Lucia:耶小心
Lucia: Yeah, be careful.
Shure: 悟性很高
Shure: You catch on quickly.
Lucia:因为感觉这塑料很脆的
Lucia: Because this plastic feels very brittle.
Lucia:样子我害怕太使劲给它没啥 了
Lucia: I'm afraid if I press too hard, it'll break.
Shure: 这个可以
Shure: This is fine.
Shure: 一眼就可以只摁这两
Shure: You just need to press these two.
Jake:要摁紧一点
Jake: Press it a bit tighter.
Lucia: 稍微摁紧一点 对吧
Lucia: Press it a bit tighter, right?
Shure: 没有他那个
Shure: Not like that.
Shure: 不不不用弹那个
Shure: No, no, don't press that one.
Jake:摁紧就得
Jake: Press it tight.
Lucia:所以就是
Lucia: So, basically...
Jake:不是
Jake: No.
Shure: 只摁这俩
Shure: Just press these two.
Jake:他应该是一个扣然后摁紧就哦
Jake: It should be one clip, and then press it tight, oh.
Lucia:这样子对吧
Lucia: Like this, right?
Shure: 对吧
Shure: Right?
Lucia:现在应该不会再开了
Lucia: It shouldn't open now.
Lucia:好了
Lucia: Alright.
Jake:我再试试
Jake: Let me try again.
Lucia:可以了我觉得
Lucia: I think it's good now.
Lucia:哈哈哈有点吓人我看看
Lucia: Hahaha, it's a bit scary, let me see.
Jake:算了算了
Jake: Forget it, forget it.
Lucia:哎呀咦
Lucia: Oh no.
Lucia:对就是你看他拉的时候他就会那个啥
Lucia: Yes, see, when he pulls it, it does that.
Lucia:就这样吧
Lucia: Just leave it like this.
Lucia:没事可以了
Lucia: It's fine, it's okay.
Jake:它怎么一直在响
Jake: Why does it keep making noise?
Jake:我摁多少下都在响
Jake: No matter how many times I press it, it keeps making noise.
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia:没事不管了
Lucia: It's fine, just ignore it.
Lucia:就这样吧
Lucia: Just leave it like this.
Jake:挺好现在应该很稳定
Jake: It's pretty good, it should be stable now.
Lucia:我觉得挺好
Lucia: I think it's pretty good.
Jake:竟然对齐了
Jake: It's actually aligned.
Jake:哎没对齐就这样
Jake: Oh no, it's not aligned, just leave it.
Lucia:还差一点没事我觉得
Lucia: It's a bit off, but it's fine, I think.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:可能还有什么地方没有扣
Lucia: Maybe there's something not clicked in.
Shure: 看谁不轻易
Shure: See, it's not easy.
Lucia:扣紧还
Lucia: Tighten it more.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Lucia:好一会就可以把它搬上去了
Lucia: Okay, we can move it up in a bit.
Shure: 嗯魔音罐耳
Shure: Hmm, the magic sound canister.
Lucia:还有一个桌布
Lucia: There's another tablecloth.
Lucia:然后快上
Lucia: Then quickly put it on.
Lucia:他会变成蓝色
Lucia: It will turn blue.
Lucia:因为我买不到蓝色的桌子
Lucia: Because I couldn't buy a blue table.
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Lucia:这个是他的轮子不安了吧
Lucia: This is the wheel, isn't it installed?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:哦麻烦死了
Lucia: Oh, it's so troublesome.
Lucia:为啥只有仨
Lucia: Why are there only three?
Lucia:应该有4个
Lucia: There should be four.
Lucia:哦谢谢
Lucia: Oh, thank you.
Jake:这挺好玩
Jake: This is pretty fun.
Lucia:那个是可心的的耳机套
Lucia: That's Kexin's headphone cover.
Jake:哦 怎么缺一半
Jake: Oh, why is it missing half?
Shure: 我们已经成功教会谢彬竹吉他了
Shure: We've successfully taught Xie Bin to play the guitar.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:弹一弹一首
Jake: Play a song
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:他怎么样挺好
Jake: How's he doing? Pretty good.
Shure: 有天赋
Shure: He's talented.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈你真的爱他吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, do you really love him? Hahaha
Jake:许艺 秀艺 续艺
Jake: Xu Yi, Xiu Yi, Xu Yi
Jake:我草
Jake: Damn
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks
Jake:哦好嘞
Jake: Oh, okay
Jake:怎么啦
Jake: What's wrong?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia:算了要不然就要不然就
Lucia: Never mind, or just, or just...
Lucia:就让他这样算了
Lucia: Just leave it like this.
Jake:你要拆哪个我帮你拆一下试试
Jake: Which one do you want to take apart? I'll help you.
Lucia:没事我觉得就把他这样拼算了
Lucia: It's fine, I think we should just leave it as it is.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay
Jake:好
Jake: Alright
Lucia:就是只有中间的这个是偏偏右的
Lucia: Only the one in the middle is slightly off to the right.
Lucia:底下两个都是都是正的
Lucia: The bottom two are aligned.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh
Jake:可能就是
Jake: Maybe it's
Jake: 1/3次频率
Jake: 1/3 frequency
Lucia:1/3次频率
Lucia: 1/3 frequency
Jake:或者2/3次频率
Jake: Or 2/3 frequency
Lucia: 2/3次频率
Lucia: 2/3 frequency
Jake:中间是好的
Jake: The middle one is good.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh
Lucia: 那为什么我们不把
Lucia: Then why don't we
Lucia:那个水果是公司2/3次
Lucia: Treat the 2/3 one as standard.
Lucia:频率就把那个1/3那当成次品
Lucia: And consider the 1/3 one as substandard.
Jake:这
Jake: This
Lucia: 我就说我设计出来就这样吧
Lucia: I'll just say it's my design.
Lucia: 这是我专门独创的设计
Lucia: This is my unique creation.
Jake:这是要转一下 这上面是这个
Jake: You need to turn it, this part is...
Jake:这感觉
Jake: This feels
Lucia: 唉 等等
Lucia: Hey, wait...
Jake:这合理不
Jake: Does this make sense?
Lucia:这这这不合理
Lucia: This, this, this is unreasonable.
Jake:这 这
Jake: This, this...
Alice:我买的挂毯可以洗一下吗
Alice: Can I wash the tapestry I bought?
Jake:可以洗
Jake: You can wash it.
Jake:我去这怎么
Jake: How do I...
Lucia:光把说或者光把上面这个这个取下来
Lucia: Just remove this part or just take this down.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:不太好取
Jake: It's not easy to remove.
Jake:想想它是不是观察一下
Jake: Maybe we should observe it a bit.
Jake:要不把这个拆了观察一下
Jake: How about we take this apart and check it out?
Lucia:这也行也可以
Lucia: That works too.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:就要不就还是把这个这个
Lucia: Or maybe just take this part...
Jake:哎哟我去这一层怎么怎么开了
Jake: Oh man, how did this layer open up?
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Jake:哇靠 这怎么开了
Jake: Wow, how did this open up?
Jake:这真的能开吗
Jake: Can this really be opened?
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Oh my...
Jake: 应该是有一个卡扣
Jake: There should be a latch.
Jake: 这个地方
Jake: This part.
Jake: 他这都卡扣的
Jake: It’s all clipped here.
Jake: 他怎么他怎么能让他卡扣卡进去
Jake: How can you get it clipped in?
Jake: 如果这装的不对的话
Jake: If this isn’t installed correctly,
Jake: 怎么能让卡扣卡进去
Jake: how can it clip in?
Jake: 这根应该是扣上的
Jake: This rod should be clipped on.
Jake: 我因为我 我感觉这边
Jake: Because I feel here...
Jake: 是有一个凸起
Jake: there’s a bump.
Lucia: 哦对对
Lucia: Oh, yes, yes.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 有道理 嗯那这
Lucia: Makes sense. Hmm, then this...
Lucia: 挂了
Lucia: It's stuck.
Jake:哦哟 我去我去
Jake: Oh man, I’ll go, I’ll go.
Lucia: 它这里有个扣它就应该
Lucia: There’s a clip here, it should...
Lucia: 应该也有能比如说
Lucia: There should be a way to, like...
Lucia: 怎么样能让它脱开的方法
Lucia: figure out how to unclip it.
Lucia: 就跟修玩具一样
Lucia: Just like fixing a toy.
Jake:嗯
Lucia: 稍等啊再放远再放远一点反正就剩一层
Lucia: Hold on, move it further away, a bit more. There's only one layer left anyway.
Lucia: 我看别太使劲把这个地方给他掰断了
Lucia: Don't use too much force, you might break it here.
Jake:有点难
Jake: It's a bit hard.
Lucia: 嗯确实
Lucia: Yeah, indeed.
Jake: 要不就
Jake: How about...
Jake: 要不就转一圈转一圈有用吗
Jake: How about we spin around? Will spinning around help?
Jake:呃 咱应该是什么效果
Jake: Uh, what effect should we have?
Jake: 咱应该是这个效果啊
Jake: We should have this effect, right?
Lucia: 啊对对对可以行
Lucia: Ah, yeah, yeah, that works.
Jake: 它在也很有限
Jake: It's quite limited though.
Lucia: 这个要把他
Lucia: This, you need to...
Lucia: 对对这样就可以啦
Lucia: Yeah, like this, it's fine.
Lucia: 然后这边在把它放进去就行啦
Lucia: And then you just put it in here, that's it.
Lucia: 主要它不要掉就行好了可以了
Lucia: Mainly, it shouldn't fall, that's it. Okay, done.
Jake: 好合理太合理了
Jake: Alright, that's reasonable. Very reasonable.
Jake: 提拉米苏要干什么
Jake: What do we need Tiramisu for?
Jake: 哎不对肉松小子要要干什么
Jake: Oh no, what do we need the meat floss kid for?
Tasha:：先把东西洗了嘛
Tasha: First, we should wash the stuff.
Tasha: 呃这些不是我的也可以不洗
Tasha: Uh, these aren't mine, so it's okay not to wash them.
Tasha: 就是现在还用不到
Tasha: We don't need them right now anyway.
Jake: 好我先洗我看到什么洗什么
Jake: Alright, I'll wash whatever I see.
Jake: 柯欣在干啥
Jake: What is Kexin doing?
Jake: 这这是啥
Jake: What's this?
Jake: 哦可以
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake: 在玩哎
Jake: Playing, huh?
Jake: 露亚要不你俩做个小狗
Jake: Lucia, how about you two make a puppy?
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or...
Lucia:可以 笔呢
Lucia: Sure, where's the pen?
Jake: 笔到了一波快递
Jake: The pen is with the courier.
Jake: 咱看有没有用可以
Jake: Let's see if it's useful.
Jake: 问问问问问
Jake: Ask, ask, ask, ask.
Jake: 问一问
Jake: Ask around.
Jake: 雨轩老师
Jake: Yuxuan teacher.
Jake: 你的快递那个笔有到吗
Jake: Did your courier with the pen arrive?
Jake: 看对看一下
Jake: Take a look.
Jake: 如果有的话能有点用
Jake: If it did, it might be useful.
Katrina:  他说已签收啊
Katrina: He said it’s been delivered.
Katrina:  那他去拿了吧
Katrina: Then he should go get it.
Katrina:  已签收没签收的话他会发
Katrina: If it’s delivered, if not, he would send it.
Jake: 嗯嗯嗯看一看
Jake: Mm, mm, mm, take a look.
Jake: 你看看你写的是我的名字吧
Jake: Check if you wrote my name on it.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia: 哪些是可以拆的呢
Lucia: Which ones can be taken apart?
Jake:我只知道我看看是谁呀
Jake: I only know... let me see who it is.
Jake: 这咋没名字啊
Jake: Why is there no name?
Tasha: 哦不是那我就不敢拆了
Tasha: Oh, no, then I don't dare to open it.
Lucia: 没事里面还有一层
Lucia: It's okay, there's another layer inside.
Jake: 哇哦哎
Jake: Wow, hey!
Lucia: 这好像是我的
Lucia: This seems to be mine.
Jake: 好请
Jake: Alright, please.
Lucia: 吃瓜吃到自己头上的感觉
Lucia: Feels like I'm the one caught in the act.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 这些笔有用吗
Jake: Are these pens useful?
Alice: 这些笔
Alice: These pens...
Lucia:可以用
Lucia: They can be used.
Jake: 那就用吧
Jake: Then let's use them.
Jake:没得用
Jake: No use.
Jake: 没得哎呦你这个挺好看啥眼缘
Jake: No use... oh, this one looks nice, what a good pick.
Lucia: 这是一个那个灯
Lucia: This is a... lamp.
Jake: 这是个灯
Jake: This is a lamp.
Lucia: 对这是一个
Lucia: Yes, this is a...
Alice:这个是买来用来干嘛 的
Alice: What did you buy this for?
Jake: 画眼睛画狗眼晴
Jake: To draw eyes, dog eyes.
Jake: 别画鼻画狗脸
Jake: Don't draw a nose, draw a dog's face.
Lucia:但是水纹灯太贵了
Lucia: But the water ripple lamp is too expensive.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 然后我就决定换一个小夜灯
Lucia: So I decided to get a small night light instead.
Jake: 这是什么这是啥 呀
Jake: What is this? What is this?
Lucia: 这是一个游戏
Lucia: This is a game.
Lucia: 里这是那个游戏的场景
Lucia: This is a scene from that game.
Lucia: 这个游戏叫纪念碑谷
Lucia: The game is called Monument Valley.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 我觉得你应该 听说过就是
Lucia: I think you should have heard of it.
Lucia: 啊就是大概咱上高中或者刚大学那会它很火
Lucia: It was really popular when we were in high school or just started college.
Lucia: 有是有些重比我想像的要重一些讨厌
Lucia: It's heavier than I thought, annoying.
Jake: 哦哟好重呀
Jake: Oh wow, it's heavy.
Lucia: 对 我以为它是塑料的结果它是石膏的
Lucia: Yes, I thought it was plastic, but it's actually plaster.
Jake: 行那我继续洗碗
Jake: Alright, I'll continue washing the dishes.
Jake: 这是丢大号
Jake: This is for the big trash.
Jake: 还有个蛋呢
Jake: There's also an egg.
Jake: 虽然有蚂蚁但是蚂蚁不吃东西
Jake: Although there are ants, the ants don't eat it.
Jake: 有点奇怪
Jake: A bit strange.
Jake: 呵它一般在实物上面可是它不去吃
Jake: Haha, usually it's on the food, but it doesn't eat it.
Lucia: 呃暂时还不能
Lucia: Uh, not yet.
Jake:哪个锅
Jake: Which pot?
Jake:好 行
Jake: Okay, sure.
Jake:昨天好像刷过
Jake: I think it was cleaned yesterday.
Jake:是前天刷过 我都刷了好几遍了
Jake: No, it was the day before. I've cleaned it several times.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh
Tasha: 好吧 洗吧
Tasha: Alright, let's wash it.
Jake: 呵呵牛逼不
Jake: Haha, isn't it awesome?
Jake: 没有铅笔可以买
Jake: If there's no pencil, you can buy one.
Jake: 美团外卖可以买
Jake: You can order one on Meituan.
Jake: 你要买吗
Jake: Do you want to buy it?
Jake: 我可能还要有点别的东西买
Jake: I might have some other things to buy too.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我尽力了我放弃了
Jake: I tried my best, I give up.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 还行吧
Jake: It's alright, right?
Jake: 有些变化
Jake: Some changes.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 我来交交班
Tasha: I'm taking over the shift.
Jake: 交班
Jake: Shift change.
Tasha:我把手洗一下
Tasha: I'll wash my hands.
Jake: 我去厕所洗
Jake: I'll wash mine in the restroom.
Jake: 我要干嘛
Jake: What am I doing?
Jake: 搅和是吧
Jake: Mixing, right?
Jake: 这我会
Jake: This I can do.
Lucia: 咱们有胶带吧
Lucia: Do we have tape?
Jake: 有胶带多的很
Jake: We have plenty of tape.
Jake: 胶带有黑胶带有双面胶
Jake: We have black tape and double-sided tape.
Lucia: 呃都可以
Lucia: Uh, either is fine.
Jake: 双面胶双面胶
Jake: Double-sided tape, double-sided tape.
Jake: 呃呃呃
Jake: Uh, uh, uh.
Jake: 这个是
Jake: This is...
Lucia:这这是电工胶带
Lucia: This is electrical tape.
Jake: 是贴是这些摄像头的也可以用
Jake: This can also be used for sticking those cameras.
Jake: 这个也是双面胶
Jake: This is also double-sided tape.
Jake: 我只有双面胶
Jake: I only have double-sided tape.
Jake: 嗯我不对我还有黑胶带
Jake: Uh, no, I also have black tape.
Jake: 黑胶带在哪呢  喏
Jake: Where's the black tape? There.
Lucia: 是吧其实美纹纸也可以勉强当胶带用
Lucia: Actually, masking tape can also kinda work as tape.
Lucia: 嗯可能明天或者后天到
Lucia: Hmm, maybe tomorrow or the day after.
Jake: 会在哪啊会在哪
Jake: Where could it be? Where could it be?
Jake: 会在哪呢
Jake: Where could it be?
Lucia: 哎是这个吗
Lucia: Hey, is this it?
Jake: 对是的
Jake: Yep, that's it.
Lucia:我识别的多精准
Lucia: My identification skills are on point.
Jake:那 呵呵
Jake: Yeah, haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈是
Jake: Hahaha, yeah.
Jake: 是人均AI
Jake: It's like AI for everyone.
Jake: 现在
Jake: Now,
Jake: 大家组建
Jake: everyone is assembling.
Lucia: 请在下图中点击什么什么图标那种
Lucia: Like those "click the icon in the image" things.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 哈哈就为了证明你不是机器人
Lucia: Haha, just to prove you're not a robot.
Jake:是
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:我用手
Jake: With my hands.
Jake: 我用筷子搅和是吧
Jake: I use chopsticks to stir, right?
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake: 又要吃饭了是吧
Jake: Are we eating again?
Jake: 又要点外卖的是吧
Jake: Ordering takeout again?
Jake: 晚上吃什么呢
Jake: What should we have for dinner?
Jake: 是是小狗
Jake: Yeah, it's a puppy.
Jake: 呵呵这
Jake: Haha, this...
Jake: 我那我搜一下小狗
Jake: I'll search for puppies then.
Jake: 晚上吃有
Jake: For dinner, do we have...
Jake: 有没有什么
Jake: anything?
Jake: 我们还没吃到什么
Jake: Have we missed any...
Jake: 中国特色食物吗
Jake: traditional Chinese food?
Lucia: 都可以其实你可以按着大的剪
Lucia: It's all good, you can just cut the big pieces.
Lucia: 然后剪下来再继续修改
Lucia: Then cut them down and keep modifying.
Jake:吃面吧
Jake: Let's have noodles.
Jake:我也不知道吃什么
Jake: I don't know what to eat.
Lucia: 炸酱面
Lucia: Zhajiangmian.
Jake: 吃炸酱面
Jake: Zhajiangmian it is.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 吃什么呢晚上
Jake: What should we eat tonight?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Shure:  吃什么呀
Shure: What should we eat?
Jake: 有什么我们还没吃到的
Jake: Is there anything we haven't eaten yet?
Jake: 中国特色食物呢
Jake: Any special Chinese food?
Shure:  卤煮吃过吗
Shure: Have you tried braised pork?
Shure:  但是一般人接受不了
Shure: But most people can't accept it.
Jake: 确实
Jake: True.
Shure:  就是我特爱吃卤煮
Shure: But I love braised pork.
Jake: 你要不咱就点到这吧
Jake: How about we stop here?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈可以啊
Jake: Hahaha, sure.
Katrina: 拿了一瓶
Katrina: Got a bottle.
Jake: 拿了一瓶
Jake: Got a bottle.
Nicous: 听说是中年老头的腋下
Nicous: Heard it’s from an old man's armpit.
Jake: 试试
Jake: Try it.
Jake: 那主食呢
Jake: What about the main dish?
Shure:  不不不不不
Shure: No no no no no.
Shure:  来来来正经想一下吃什么
Shure: Come on, let's seriously think about what to eat.
Jake: 你有点OK
Jake: You okay?
Jake: 然后噢好吃啥
Jake: Then, oh, what to eat?
Shure:  吃啥想想吃啥不行就
Shure: Think about what to eat, if not then...
Jake: 面
Jake: Noodles.
Jake:吃过面吗
Jake: Have you had noodles?
Shure:  哦面没吃过
Shure: Oh, haven't had noodles.
Jake: 嗯吃啥面了
Jake: Hmm, what kind of noodles?
Shure:  李先生牛肉面
Shure: Mr. Li's beef noodles.
Jake:炸酱面
Jake: Fried sauce noodles.
Nicous:  哈哈哈李先生牛肉面还有北京牛肉面
Nicous: Hahaha, Mr. Li's beef noodles, and Beijing beef noodles.
Jake: 哦真的
Jake: Oh really?
Shure:  没有这没有北京特色
Shure: No, it’s not a Beijing specialty.
Shure:  但是他很好吃
Shure: But it's delicious.
Shure:  我一直特别爱吃
Shure: I always love eating it.
Shure:  李先生牛肉面
Shure: Mr. Li's beef noodles.
Jake: 那就
Jake: Then...
Shure: 哦和府捞
Shure: Oh, Hefulou.
Shure:  呃不是啊
Shure: Uh, no, not that.
Shure:  对和府捞面还还挺好
Shure: Yeah, Hefulou noodles are quite good.
Shure:  挺好吃的啊
Shure: Pretty tasty.
Shure:  那确实
Shure: That's true.
Jake: 那就李先生吧
Jake: Then let's go with Mr. Li's.
Jake: 李先生哈
Jake: Mr. Li's, huh?
Jake: 行吧
Jake: Alright then
可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay
Jake: 牛肉面
Jake: Beef noodles
Jake: 行可以
Jake: Sure, that's fine
Jake: 哎点吧点吧
Jake: Hey, go ahead and order
Jake: 嗯李先生牛肉面
Jake: Hmm, Mr. Li's beef noodles
Alice:这个可以用吗
Alice: Can we use this?
Jake: 可以可以用可以用
Jake: Yes, we can use it, we can use it
Lucia: 哎最终竟然选了李先生牛肉面
Lucia: Wow, we actually chose Mr. Li's beef noodles in the end
Jake:哟哟哟
Jake: Yo, yo, yo
Jake: 是行不
Jake: Is that alright?
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Yes
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 这我也没吃过
Jake: I've never tried this before
Jake: 这什么时候开的店
Jake: When did this place open?
Lucia: 好早以前了
Lucia: A long time ago
Lucia: 有一段时间店很多
Lucia: There were many stores for a while
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright
Jake: 我搅和的
Jake: I'm mixing it
Jake: 我我还得再搅和吗
Jake: Should I keep mixing it?
Tasha: 不用了
Tasha: No need
Jake: 啊你刚刚画的是狗
Jake: Ah, you just drew a dog
Lucia: 对我打了个草稿
Lucia: Yes, I made a sketch
Lucia: 我想把五官定一下位
Lucia: I wanted to position the facial features
Jake: 哦确实挺像猫
Jake: Oh, it really looks like a cat
Lucia: 但是发现就是对
Lucia: But I found out it does, yeah
Jake: 像猫精灵
Jake: Like a cat elf
Lucia: 就是我打算
Lucia: So I plan to
Lucia: 我打算换一种
Lucia: I plan to change it
Lucia: 换一种狗
Lucia: To another kind of dog
Lucia: 不是我照着这
Lucia: Not following this
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 我照着这个萨摩耶画的
Lucia: I was drawing a Samoyed
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 眼睛大小应该差不多
Lucia: The eyes should be about the same size
Lucia: 真实话术可以往两边再
Lucia: For realism, I can move them further apart
Jake: 你这狗画的挺像狗
Jake: Your dog drawing looks like a real dog
Jake: 一点好哈哈哈
Jake: A bit, haha
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake: 没有挺像狗
Jake: No, it really looks like a dog
Jake: 挺像狗
Jake: Kind of looks like a dog.
Lucia: 对那就这样
Lucia: Yeah, just like that.
Jake: 好嘞来请
Jake: Alright, go ahead.
Jake: 可以
Jake: It's fine.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 点菜点菜
Jake: Let's order, let's order.
Jake: 百忙之中点俩菜
Jake: Order two dishes in the midst of being busy.
Jake: 我要干什么呢
Jake: What am I supposed to do?
Tasha:包上就行
Tasha: Just wrap it up.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我也是招牌牛肉面啊
Jake: I also have the signature beef noodles.
Jake: 有人不是招牌牛肉面吗
Jake: Does anyone not have the signature beef noodles?
Lucia: 不知道哎
Lucia: No idea.
Jake: 吃什么呀
Jake: What are we eating?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 呃 是哪一个
Jake: Uh, which one is it?
Jake: 是哪一个
Jake: Which one is it?
Jake: 哪一个来着
Jake: Which one is it again?
Jake: 这
Jake: This one.
Alice:有双面胶之类的吗
Alice: Do you have double-sided tape or something?
Jake: 有有双面胶
Jake: Yes, yes, we have double-sided tape.